this is the national debt the total
amount that we as a country owe to our
creditors the combined sum of all our
annual federal budget deficits lumped
together you might have heard about it
our main story tonight concerns the
national debt the deficits and how we're
going to pay for that the national debt
has hit an all-time high here in the u.s
we have by far the biggest national debt
in the world and right now it's the
highest it's ever been even when you
compare it to the massive size of the
u.s economy the debt to gdp ratio we're
still pretty close to record highs
you've probably seen these charts before
their favorites on cable shows and in
newspaper columns they even make the
occasional appearance on the house floor
but what if i told you
maybe they don't matter
let's back up
[Music]
tonight i want to talk about the debate
we've been having in washington over the
national debt after the great recession
the obama administration spent hundreds
of billions of dollars to revive the us
economy which sent the national debt
soaring economists and politicians were
worried about what would happen with the
u.s borrowing and spending so much so
fast would interest rates spike would
inflation take off would the economy
come crumbling down crushed by the
weight of an unprecedented fiscal burden
it did not and inflation didn't take off
and interest rates on the government's
debt did not spike in fact and this is
key interest rates fell and then just
kept falling low rates are going to be
with us for a lot longer low rates near
zero rates forever and a day very low
interest rates for a very long time when
the dust settled from the financial
crisis the biggest criticism was that
the government hadn't done enough and
should have borrowed and spent even more
to speed the recovery along now enter
two famous economists larry summers the
former u.s treasury secretary and
olivier blanchard the former chief
economist at the imf at a 2017
conference about lessons learned from
the great recession these two asked a
big question if you're borrowing money
to help your economy grow and the growth
you're getting is higher than the
interest you pay why not just spend more
money here's how blanchard put it you
can still issue that and in effect not
repay it if you never repaid the debt to
gdp ratio will still eventually converge
it will never explode it's very clever
it can be done the idea that federal
debt isn't always so bad is not a new
one it's a core belief of modern
monetary theory a school of economic
thinking that's been gaining traction
over the last few years as the debt has
gotten larger but what blanchard and
summers said was rather than focusing so
much on this chart we should be thinking
about this one the interest that the
government pays on all that debt as a
percent of gdp because interest rates
have stayed so low the cost of paying
for the us debt has also stayed low even
as the debt itself has taken off so if
we look at this chart you would find the
trends
much less alarming politically i
realized how much of a bond
this is but
this is what comes out the big
implication is this that countries with
super low interest rates like the us can
afford to spend a lot more and run up
much bigger deficits without facing such
negative consequences
that idea has caught on among economists
and investors who have started coming
around to a whole new way of thinking
about government borrowing and top
economic policy makers haven't been far
behind u.s treasury secretary janet
yellen gave testimony in march and she
was asked specifically if the growing
debt was cause for concern her response
might sound familiar interest payments
on that debt
relative to gdp have not gone up at all
and
so i think that's a more meaningful
metric of
the burden of the debt on society this
change helps explain the biden
administration's approach to the
economic recovery they're taking what
economists see as a calculated risk a
bet made in trillions of dollars whose
stakes are no less than the future of a
nation and of a global financial system
built around borrowed money and for the
moment with interest rates still so low
the bet appears to be paying off